[Music]
there's somebody driving into town the
first time you wouldn't think there was
a lot here because 95% of it is hiding
underground people drive in and go where
is the place I don't understand Cuba
Petey is from the aboriginal Cooper
picky which means white man and a hole
at the moment upstairs
it is about 122 degrees Fahrenheit down
here we're sitting on about 71 72
degrees no air conditioning necessary
well right out in the middle of nowhere
it takes a day to drive here from
Adelaide I'd say there's about a
thousand underground dwellings and at
least 1500 people living on the ground
we've got five underground churches
we've got underground motels there's
some amazing underground homes here many
bedrooms underground workshop you name
it underground we've pretty well got it
I bought my dog out as a fairly small
two-bedroom that I got and I've been
extending it over the years some of this
I blasted out what I could get away with
it the cops don't life is blasting
intent we don't do it anymore
back in the old days if somebody was
gonna have a baby
we'd rock around there with a couple of
compressors on a weekend and some
jackhammers and a couple of cartons of
beer and by 2:00 Sunday night we dug out
of room cemented the floor and my it up
and there's your new baby's room honey
even though we're so far away
geographically from anywhere else but I
know why but we just loved the place to
piss
when you see the players get the ball in
their home for the first time it's a
cross between intrigue and excitement
it's great to see him try and bounce the
ball and to see it actually bounce away
it can make the best of people look
really really silly the number one sport
in Australia is Australian rules
football it's basically a cross between
rugby and soccer and the fans go crazy
for it there's one problem they don't
have enough tall people so what do they
do they come to the States
[Music]
this combines the u.s. AFL combine and
we started this four years ago basically
in a search for four guys six foot seven
and above
and these tall American athletes they
don't really need to know a lot about
Australia it's a home of the Kangaroos I
think I know a lot of kangaroos I hit a
lot about kangaroos and spiders and
snakes in selecting these athletes we
predominantly look for guys that are
hungry most of the participants
predominantly come from basketball the
concept of basketball in terms of the
athlete being in traffic and having
spatial awareness and those sorts of
things is really transferable to our
game which is good news because less
than 2 percent of college basketball
players will make it to the pros the
Australian Football League gives them
another chance to live out their dreams
of being a pro athlete most of the
participants are quite shocked till when
they say the game for the first time the
question is what are the athletes think
of all this when I got to come over I
thought it was fake actually I thought
it was a scam first thing I thought that
was a scam I thought there was a contact
and one person absolutely
what is Australian football skepticism
aside how do you teach these guys a game
they never even heard of before
so the comboing kicks off in the early
pace with a physical testing and then
start to build into the skills the
basics of handballing the ability to see
what they like with their hands then we
can start to get into the more
competitive stuff where they might crash
& bash into each other which they love
that
[Music]
this is Mason Cox he played basketball
at Oklahoma State two years ago he was
just like one of these guys on the
combine now he's playing professionally
in Australia this fuzzy little creature
is a Kaka and these guys live here off
the west coast of Australia on Rottnest
Island Crocker's are not only cute they
are camera-ready and they're taking the
internet by storm so let's start at the
beginning what is a Kaka Oquawka is a
small wallaby it comes from the same
family as a kangaroo and physically
they've got thick brown fur they've got
long tails and they hop around hawkers
thrive on Rottnest Island because they
don't have any predators over here so
there's no foxes we have the largest
viable population of about 10,000 oh
sorry and you are
my name's Cassie Anna GREs and I'm a
conservation officer on right nest
island in my role I'm responsible for
managing conservation programs and
there's one online trend that has really
helped these animals a cooker selfie but
make sure you're getting it right how to
take a caucus selfie step one a camera
step two a corker but don't touch the
caucus ah nope or feed them it's 150
dollar fine these guys don't need the
food they naturally graze their way
through the islands vegetation and I
also really love the savings that we
plan as part of our revegetation
projects that we have implemented by our
environment technicians sorry about that
guys thanks for all your hard work and
what makes these guys so great for
taking selfies around the settlement
area the Crockers are a lot friendlier
they've become used to people so their
natural behaviour changed but out in the
reserve where they're actually still
exhibiting their natural behavior there
will be a lot more wary of people we
have to know are they actually smiling
in photos yeah they're not actually
smiling in the photos it's just the
natural shape of their mouth which comes
up at the side which
makes them look like they're smiling the
popularity of the [ __ ] selfie has given
us the opportunity to be able to raise
awareness about the Crockers
particularly on the mainland that are
under threat so we use that as a
platform to educate the public and also
educate them about appropriate
interaction with wildlife so finally a
good cause for selfies meet Morrison and
tingoora two adorable dingoes no these
aren't pet dogs they're actually wild
animals dingoes are australia's wild dog
considered a cultural icon but due to
interbreeding pure dingers have become
harder to spot hence both Morrison and
tangora's similar appearance to domestic
dogs dingers are thought to have been
introduced to Australia three to four
thousand years ago they are Australia's
largest terrestrial predator dingoes
hunt everything from rodents and birds
to larger prey like kangaroos they are a
big part of Aboriginal Australian
culture yet a seen as pests by livestock
farmers due to perceived attacks on
animals hunting for their skin and
interbreeding has left their population
vulnerable this is the dingo
[Music]
quote it's a 360-degree game there's no
padding there is a high risk involved in
it because it is a full-contact sport
and now you really can cop it from any
angle but we're pretty tough and you get
straight back up from Cuffy I'm Chloe
and I'm a loons footballer let's go
girls
[Music]
IFL or the Australian Football League is
best described as a combination of rugby
football and soccer I think have you
asked any Australian it's a really big
deal it defines us it's a part of our
culture
I think everyone has AFL team that they
support my uncle played football for
calling me so I grew up watching him and
I immediately wanted to do it back when
I was a little girl I actually played
football for 3 to 4 years but then
there's that drop-off that a lot of
girls have because there is no pathway
into a women's sporting career in 2017 a
women's league was officially introduced
good stretch for all Australian but if a
woman's changed the path of life for me
that I never thought I'd have it's
bought out the little girl's dream that
I had back when I did play football
I think the AFL women's is breaking down
a lot of barriers that once existed
amongst women in sport no matter what
race what sexual identity you are it
really doesn't matter and anyone can
play some people just don't agree that
women should be playing football so
that's probably a challenge that I face
and that the whole league face as well
the best way to react to all the
criticism is just not to react at all
and keep doing what we enjoy one hope
that I have is that if any little girl
or boy looks on the TV they know full
well that that's a sport that they can
go into no matter if it's being played
by men or women
[Music]